[موسيقى]
الاقتصاد العالمي طبعا يهمنا نموه وقوته
يجب ان ننسى
موضوع الهام جدا ان الطلب على البترول
واستدانته يعتمد على
وضع الاقتصاد العالمي وصحه الاقتصاد
العالمي ونمو الاقتصاد العالمي في الدرجه
الاولى ولذلك هذه المنظومه الثلاثيه
تهمنا جميعا بدون بدون ان يفرق بين هذا
الارتباطهما مع بعض
[موسيقى]
والله الهجوم احيانا مصالح سياسيه في
الدراجه الاولى
عند القرارات التي اتخذها اوبك بلس او
الاوبك في صالح هذه الدول او تلك هذه
السبب الرئيسي في الهجوم اما ما مساله
المصلحه العامه لا المملكه فهي ثابته
واستقرار البترول واحد من ضمنها
واستقرار البترول وهدف من الاستقرار
البترول موجود قبل الاوبك وقبل حتى قبل ان
تنشره
[موسيقى]
البترول
يحتاج الى استثمار بعيد المدى
واموال طائله
لا تستطيع ان تترك السوق بدون توازن والا
انهارت السوق ونهارت السوق توقفت
الاستثمارات ويتوقفت الاستمارات
وارتفعت الاسعار بشكل نهائي ولذلك هم
الجميع منذ البدايه
بدايه البترول وسلع التجاريه وهامه
وبدات السيارات
وغيرها استقرار السوق
[موسيقى]